I'm mark I'm here - we're here today
we're here today to take a bus cool to
take the BuzzFeed quiz read this out
through really it out loud so this quiz
is called create a dating profile and
when we will reveal again you'll get a
match
anybody here signal yes yes my son my
older son well both up again actually
choose a username first one is Billy
II wish fan 11
Alysha fan and second one is single
Pringle
super no no no bulbs 11 or soda / Pepsi
what do you think they're forgetting
Farrow both of us which ones - us
I don't know what you do this quicker
all right so just pick one Pepsi okay so
no Pepsi
what does your profile picture look like
a cute photo our friend took of me a
selfie with a snapshot filter photo of
me by a sunset or a picture of my best
friend I guess what does your profile
picture look like okay
modem with me buy a sunset what does
your bio is safe left-handed or
right-handed no left-handed or right
minded single and ready to mingle I
looking for a date open to anybody
a variant okay that's interesting
we're not left has single right
[Music]
hey there hey there you how will you
message someone that you are interested
in first one is hey what's up how are
you what's cooking she loves to cook
okay how would you react to someone
ghosting you I think I know it goes me
oh I didn't know that so how would you
react someone ghosting you
you know I respect your decision ask for
anyone
spam that with text Wow interesting
question to answer true
[Music]
nly no I'm going to do this one I
wouldn't do this one alright let's go
with yours you're right okay you're
ignoring a respect their decision what's
this
so it says you got so sick no you got no
so sorry what's that mean you should
maybe try to find someone in person
wait was it wasn't he you good
no sorry you don't know that we have it
good do you ha are you the reason that
my older Center is not dating right now
huh he's a good guy oh my gosh don't let
him see this because he'll kill me yeah
I didn't know what ghosting yes I know
what ghosting means now and I know I'm
not good it's not Halloween I'm not good
at doing these you what's good about
this really if God forbid we should ever
split up we know we're not every
successful funny guy okay so this what
this really does it keeps grandparents
together
[Music]